hornets no timeouts six seconds
five walkers with a three to tie yes
we've seen it before you know how this
ends
[Applause]
with
[Music]
yes he will
oh that was a pass to zeller
dallenberg got in front of it oh blocked
out of bounds
kimba walker the human eraser
down the lane drive shoots scores
game over
they'll be there
[Applause]
walker leans in gets the three
wow they're going to take a look at it
but when it's going right
for k-dub he knows it
[Applause]
walker gets into the paint spins uh
not a person in a seat here right now
here's walker
painting a screen williams walker with
the handle takes it puts it up
[Applause]
oh my goodness aaron brooks is quick
he's got another
handle the fire wants to stop on the
dime right there
loses aaron brooks comes right back
fakes going over the screen
wow taylor in the corner
eight on the shot clock amber works
against tyler
oh look at that behind the back ball on
the right
he says oh i'm too far on the right
bucket here going into the fourth
quarter would be nice
oh campbell with the shimmy
[Music]
what a first half for kimbo walker
stare magruder down a little shimmy
before he pulls up
and he knows it's down
[Applause]
wow what an effort kemba one-man show
move by kevin look three raptors around
him he spins
and then fades away over the top left
knew exactly how much time he had to
work with
and he gets the bucket just in time
has not scored in 17 minutes of court
time
he's taking a holiday
[Applause]
that was a 16th main field though for
the hornets in this quarter alone kevin
walker
toy for the defense changing speed
it starts with kemba jj reddick on it
crosses him over draws contacts
garrett no foul somehow
but score the goal and the guy with the
biggest heart attacks the paint crossed
over
gets to the paint nice he knows i've got
to face the big guy
a little hesitation and the
concentration of kimmel walker to
shoot that ball while he's getting hit
on the waist right there embiid
hits him on the waist can tie with the
two
kemba off the window
butler thinks he's got it a quick step
back high over the top of butler and
it's saturday night yeah the banks are
open in uptown
and 15 is cashing it in
kemba has mere titch on it
[Applause]
slides inside somehow got it past
davison
just a moment ago he showed you what
he's all about somehow getting it past
one of the best shot blockers in the
world throwing it up on the backboard
and through
[Applause]
kemba doing his thing he's got lyles on
skates gets his
pass
[Music]
i would just go for the first fake and
leave it alone
kemba walker back on the floor
[Music]
kim book got green up in the air
oh my just got crushed by green
and he hits the shot how did he do
that sidestep and a good ball fake
and it's a three oh absolutely i mean
the concentration that it takes
to make that shot they used to have good
form on that shot after getting hit
teams over the years have tried to use
the altitude to their advantage but not
this year's punch oh
kemba oh most acrobatic layup of the
year
switched hands rocked the cradle
finished with the left hand breaking
ankles that's what it's called
cross it over hang split
and the hornets get into the back court
kemba's got it they can't catch him
that'll do it the hornet's a winner on a
sunday night in phoenix
and kevin hill from half court it didn't
count it was after the buzzer
but what a way to put an exclamation
point on a w
he slid to the corner kallistein threw
it where he was
kept a circus shot to beat the buzzer
put this in the words my man just time
and score
and nobody does it best than the point
guards in this league
and he is one of the best that we have
in our game
subtle shove off fading to the corner
because of that push-off nothing but net
pass deflected kemba still redirects it
through the hoop
another bucket for the hornets
trying to go back to turn stripped
[Music]
oh nice pass oh nifty fast
take a look mike off the transition
there's kemba walker driving dumps it
late
and jalen brown with a 360 jam
that fast break brought to you by fios
by verizon
one two
[Applause]
walker a little dance man goes by
knocks down a three
[Applause]
two big shots by the celtics at the end
of the first
and second quarter devin booker selected
by commissioner adam silva to replace
the uh injured
damian oh what a move
take those ankles
team lebron
if another free throw puts it in 11
point lead for miami
walker with seconds remaining from eight
court good if it goes got it
got it nails that half court shot kemba
walker
for them late in that third quarter but
now kimball walker
knocks down this dagger from about 50
feet the ruling on the floor is a good
three-point basket
all year walker to smart
one second to go good luck kemba good
walker beats the buzzer says let me put
this three on your head
a little cardiac kemba at the buzzer as
the celtics
and a chance to go up 3-0 toronto does
have a foul to give walker in the double
team gets by
walker dishes ties with the dunk with
point five left lowry stepped up to help
ciacom got looked off he was running out
to the three
you watch ciaco here that's his sink he
should be down on tice
he was worried about the pass coming out
to the three
jalen clean look how did kemba see him
yeah
great pass by kemba it's all through the
gaps the longer you look the more there
is to like kendall walker
he didn't even look they did not not
once
i think he closed his eyes amazing
let's take a look look at the eyes nope
did he look nope
nope corner of his eyes please someone
on the zoom call
afterwards asked kemba did you see
jaylen brown wide open for three